locataire d'un côté et propriétaire de
l'autre la confédération nationale du
logement des yvelines accompagne les
locataires dans leurs démarches
alors que l'union nationale des
propriétaires immobilier 78 conseil les
investisseurs chacun campe sur ses
positions notamment sur l'encadrement
des loyers ce qui est beaucoup plus
grave c'est pour les nouveaux
investisseurs parce que les nouveaux
investisseurs aujourd'hui vont à
décourager à rentrer dans des
dispositifs locatifs et nous ce que l'on
rencontre aujourd'hui au niveau de notre
association des yvelines c'est que on a
un certain nombre de propriétaires qui
ont décidé de ne plus louer dès
l'instant que leur appartement est libre
alors ce dispositif sur le principe même
on est d'accord faut limiter les loyers
ils sont beaucoup trop élevés en france
ça c'est clair maintenant le dispositif
si nous nous ce qui ce fait pas
globalement instauré à paris cet
instrument devrait être étendu dans
certaines communes du département des
yvelines
son principe fixé un loyer maximum aux
bailleurs pour limiter les excès parmi
les villes concernées voisins le
bretonneux avec 73 % de propriétaires et
11 % de locataires
c'est bien ça me faire plaisir aux
locataires souffre c'est une bonne chose
mais en même temps la crainte qu'on peut
avoir c'est peut-être par rapport aux
investisseurs il faudrait pas que ça
décourage justement des personnes
d'acheter des biens pour les louer
ensuite s'ils n'ont pas la maîtrise sur
leur loyer une bataille de chiffres
règne entre les représentants pour la
confédération nationale du logement des
yvelines les loyers ont augmenté de plus
de 30 % entre 2004 et 2014
même sur saint cyr l'école où on est par
exemple ans une petite commune j'étais
en train de regarder les agences un ca
de l'ordre entre 1000 et 1200 euros par
mois pour un port un 68 corps et c'est à
dire un outil est roi si les loyers sont
chers ce parce qu'il ya des manques de
logements les propriétaires doute de la
sincérité de ces données ils possèdent
leur propre diagnostic avec comme
conséquence une autre vision de la
politique du logement aujourd'hui
on regarde vraiment sur les yvelines
légère baisse de l'ordre de 1%
donc pourquoi encadrer des loyers qui
sont en train de baisser
les premiers résultats des études sur
l'efficacité de l'encadrement des loyers
parisiens sont attendus le jeudi 15
juillet date de restitution des
conclusions de l'agencé départementale
d'information sur le logement